c'est fait voici une partie du mur à la
frontière entre les etats-unis et le
mexique
l'artiste ait surpris parce qu'il a
constaté états unis on pense que ça va
être très très tendue puis ont
finalement c'est très relax ou le long
des frontières tonight i'm shipping qui
ce qui n'est à nous notamment par le
discours de nos troupes à la nation ce
sauna c'est ainsi incroyablement change
par rapport à la réalité de la situation
fasciné par les liens entre la
géopolitique et là ils présentent le
fruit de son travail dans une
installation intitulée les murs du
désordre ce tous mes installations
interactives qui a pour but de faire
vivre physiquement la présence des murs
avec une approche documentaire
l'oeuvre est composée de trois murs
constitué par l'artiste celui à la
frontière entre la palestine et israël
celui entre les etats-unis et le mexique
ainsi que celui qui sépare la ville de
belfast en irlande du nord
aujourd'hui on est à environ 74 mur
frontalier dans le monde
et puis quand j'ai commencé à faire sur
le projet ça fait maintenant six ans que
je travaille sur ce projet et on parle
de 50 et quelques mots
donc c'est un espèce de tendance qui est
vraiment forte et puis qui vont en
augmentant c'est une permission qu'on se
donne d'un point de vue social pour
faire vivre le sentiment d'exclusion par
un petit trou il est possible de
regarder de l'autre côté la politologue
elizabeth vallée trouve l'expérience
intéressante
l'intérêt d'une exposition comme celle
ci c'est celle de nous permettre d'aller
à la rencontre du mur physiquement ce
qui est intéressant c'est de les
regarder
est ce qu'on peut faire ici de l'autre
côté du mur et avoir cette sensation de
la séparation les murs de l'installation
ont été reproduits avec les mêmes
matériaux que ceux des murs originaux
pour l'artiste les véritables murs se
trouve peut-être ailleurs puis ce qui
pour moi est
sur des réflexions encore par rapport à
ce sujet là c'est que les véritables
murs ils sont dans la tête ne sont pas
physiques ici julie jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal